[Musique]
alexandre langlois très court il nous
reste très peu de temps six mois c'est
vraiment un manque de moyens pour lutter
contre la criminalité et la délinquance
en tout cas pour rétablir un sentiment
de sécurité en france et un manque de
moyens a manque de moyens ou en partie
oui alors de formation également à
banque de aussi répartition selon les
tranches d'âge des policiers et une
volonté de toujours quoi qu'en dise je
me suis cassé hier de faire du chiffre
du chiffre pour pouvoir briller dans les
médias je vais donner un exemple très
concret avait une brigade qui faisait
beaucoup de chiffres dans un dans une
ville qui a amené cents à faire donc
c'était sans boulette de shit
il avait les félicitations régulièrement
et toutes les primes et une autre
brigade elle qui allait prendre son café
au café du coin pour discuter avec les
gens ils ont dit et puis à un moment le
cafetier leur dis mais il ya des gens de
l'autre brigade qui sont venus me voir
en disant qu'il y avait des policiers en
uniforme qui prenaient leur café je vous
ai couvert les gars ils ont dit au
contraire au contraire voir direct
comprend le café nous avec vous on le
paye s'ils veulent prendre la
température du quartier de savoir ce qui
s'y passera devant les associations les
gardiens d'immeubles discuter avec les
gens et les gens leur donne le numéro de
portable personnel pour qu'ils nous
appellent scaglia un lien de confiance
et après quand il ya quelque chose
vision et donc du meilleur enseignement
c'est du renseignement et surtout de la
confiance parce que les gens ils
appellent ils disent gênés tels
sentiments j'ai vu ça mais vous allez
voir des ébats voilà ce que vous avez vu
c'est ça ils sont rassurés il s'était
rien passé s'était fait un film sur
quelque chose de complètement inexistant
et un adverse qu'il y avait quelque
chose il n'intervenait plutôt qu'un
numéro standard 17 ou faut attendre
trois plombes voit la préfecture de
police de paris c'est un numéro surtaxé
je veux dire donc du quotidien avec de
l'être humain au centre de la population
mettant sita pensable qu'un policier y
faire ses courses soi à boire un café en
uniforme mais c'est à ce moment là qu'on
voit les gens qu'on discute c'est là
qu'on voit que les policiers sont des
êtres humains derrière l'uniforme c'est
là qu'on fait du contact et que les gens
dont 90% des cas veulent vivre
tranquillement donc ils vont parler aux
policiers pour dire bah j'ai vu ça et
nous on fait notre travail derrière pour
vérifier si oui ou non il ya quelque
chose
[Musique]